le débat de ce club consacre au 50 ans
du rassemblement national le 5 octobre
1972 Jean-Marie Le Pen fondait le Front
national pour l'unité française partie
issue de plusieurs groupes nationalistes
50 ans après le rassemblement national
compte 89 députés avec Marine Le Pen
alors tête elle a prononcé hier à un
discours dans un colloque à l'Assemblée
Samia de cher
tu as pas changé
les historiques du Front national sont
là mais pas le fondateur du parti qui
fêtait hier ses 50 ans Jean-Marie Le Pen
a assisté à distance aux coloc organisée
hier à l'Assemblée nationale un
anniversaire sans fanfare difficile de
glorifier un passé sulfureux jonché de
dérapage pour un parti en quête de
normalisation
Bruno Gollnisch lui ne renie rien et
regrette l'absence du menhir nous
n'avons pas à rougir de ce que nous
sommes dit de ce que nous avons été ni
de ce que nous avons fait au contraire
c'est à ceux qui ont conduit le pays
dans la frange où il se trouve d'avoir
honte aux parties qui se sont succédés
au pouvoir et qui n'en ont rien fait
Marine Le Pen assume la rupture avec son
père dans un mois elle passera la main
ce sera la fin d'un demi siècle de règne
du clan Le Pen à la tête du parti
bientôt le mouvement se choisira à
nouveau président qui ne sera pas Le Pen
prouvant par la même que le parti notre
parti puisse chaque jour sa vitalité
dans l'énergie militante formidable
qu'il l'anime et les belles
personnalités qui l'incarne
petit problème technique avec le sujet
on l'a vu quand même dans dans le sujet
célébration évidemment sans Jean-Marie
Le Pen et célébration sobre c'était dans
un sous-sol de l'Assemblée nationale
comment il faut interpréter ce choix de
Marine Le Pen Charles un choix entre
deux solutions possibles c'est
d'ailleurs ça gamberge effort cet été au
rassemblement national dans l'entourage
de Marine Le Pen faut-il ou non fêter
cet anniversaire parce que évidemment il
y a quelque chose il y a une certaine
fierté notamment militante d'avoir mis
au centre du débat public certains
thèmes notamment la lutte contre
l'immigration l'affirmation d'une
certaine identité enfin il y a un
continuum d'idées et qui peut être une
source de fierté pour Marine Le Pen mais
le problème c'est que quand vous fêtez
50 ans d'histoire vous risquez d'exhumer
les vieux
vous montrer que le rassemblement
national ce n'est pas le Front national
de Yassin il y a 50 ans qu'est-ce qui
reste aujourd'hui Arnaud dans le
rassemblement national de ce qui était
le Front national le nom de Le Pen
finalement parce que c'est vrai que le
parti considérablement évolué par
rapport à ce qui était le rassemblement
national pardon vous voyez moi-même on a
pu se révélateur en l'occurrence ce qui
était le Front national à ses débuts en
1972 c'est peut-être rappeler ce qui
était le Front national de ses débuts le
Front national c'est finalement la
conjonction de toute la droite et de
l'extrême droite antigoliste des années
60 et des années 70 qui est l'évalation
de ce que l'on appelait ordre nouveau
qui était réellement un mouvement qui
était qu'on peut qualifier là pour le
coup de néo-fasciste plus une droite qui
n'était pas forcément d'extrême droite
historiquement mais qui était une droite
Algérie française je rappelle que
Georges Bideau fait partie des
fondateurs du Front national même s'il
n'est pas resté longtemps il est resté
une semaine Georges Bideau qui était
quand même le successeur de Jean Moulin
à la tête du Conseil National de la
Résistance il y avait si vous voulez une
espèce de j'allais dire de My de courant
politique que Jean-Marie Le Pen a fédéré
et d'ailleurs il faut se souvenir que
lorsque le choix est fait de porter
Jean-Marie Le Pen à la tête de ce
mouvement c'est que parce que Jean-Marie
Le Pen ça va paraître tout à fait
surprenantes et considérer comme
quelqu'un de finalement c'est une espèce
de conscient de respectabilité par
rapport à des forces politiques qui sont
beaucoup plus extrémistes donc la
réalité c'est qu'en effet aujourd'hui ce
qui reste du rassemblement du Front
national c'est vraisemblablement l'image
du père un passé un certain nombre de
dérapages qui ont pesé sur l'image de de
cette formation politique et Marine Le
Pen a tout fait depuis son accession
infini pour essayer de normaliser de
banaliser ce ce parti elle y est en
partie arrivée force et de le constater
les résultats électoraux l'ont démontré
il lui reste quand même malgré tout un
certain nombre de marches à franchir qui
sont des marches qui ne relèvent plus
tellement j'allais dire presque de la
question de la respectabilité mais
plutôt de la crédibilité ce qui est tout
à fait différent en l'occurrence
c'est-à-dire est-ce que Marine Le Pen et
le rassemblement national sont une
formation politique crédible pour un
jour espérer pouvoir gouverner le pays
je crois que c'est la question
aujourd'hui qui se pose pour cette
formation politique bien plus que la
question finalement du passé qui reste
en effet présent mais qui s'est quand
même considérablement effiloché elle a
pas encore réussi à passer ce cap pour
vous Charles ce cadre de la crédibilité
alors elle elle dit aujourd'hui qu'elle
est l'opposition qu'elle souhaite
incarner un parti de gouvernement est-ce
qu'elle est vraiment perçue comme ça non
non même si en effet là en fait dans son
discours elle dit voilà la création du
Front national avec son père Jean-Marie
Le Pen c'était un parti de contestation
là-dessus elle a totalement raison quant
à la pris les reines du parti en 2011
elle a œuvré notamment avec cette
entreprise de dédiabolisation pour en
faire un aussi d'opposition ce qui est
vrai là elle clamo et fort qu'elle est
devenue un parti de gouvernement là non
non et d'ailleurs on l'a vu lors de la
dernière présidentielle l'un des
principaux handicaps en plus de la
plantation locale dont on va parler mais
c'est cette crédibilité notamment
finalement on ne voit pas dans
l'entourage de Marine Le Pen qui serait
susceptible d'être ministre de
l'Intérieur qui serait susceptible de
prendre la direction de la Banque de
France qui serait susceptible de peupler
les cabinets mystériels et avoir
finalement un personnel qui lui soit
affilié idéologiquement mais qui sont en
capacité de faire tourner les
différentes institutions de l'État il y
a eu un gros travail de dédiabolisation
en trois phases finalement quand elle
arrive en 2011 aileron avec la stratégie
de provocation de d'invectif de son père
qui est enfin ça c'est une stratégie qui
est vieille comme la démocratie enfin on
l'a déjà vu
Éric c'est ce qu'il a fait pendant la
présidentielle sur un autre bord de chez
qui et politique Sandrine Rousseau aussi
c'est-à-dire faire des provocations pour
mener des maîtres des sujets sur le
débat public elle a la rompue avec ça
elle a lissé son parti à la fin un gros
nettoyage interne il faut se rappeler de
la période de 2012 à 2017 il y avait le
secrétaire général du parti qui
s'appelait Jeanin Lacapelle qu'on
appelait loulou la poule la purge
qu'elle est dans toutes les fédérations
chasser tous les mecs qui étaient un
petit peu trop radicaux bon ça ça se
voit ça se voit dans les résultats
électoraux ça se voit dans les sondages
sont partis c'est plus normalisé mais
c'est vrai que cette cette capacité
cette cette compétence
ça reste le gros chantier pour Marine Le
Pen et le rassemblement national qui l'a
dit d'ailleurs dans cette idée de
diabolisation et dit nous avons réussi à
imposer le tempo de la vie politique en
imposant toutes les thématiques qui le
structurent est-ce qu'elle dit vrai
quand elle dit ça ou est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui finalement c'est elle qui
a changé de logiciel elle parle très peu
d'immigration elle parle beaucoup de
pouvoir d'achat ou est-ce que finalement
les idées du rassemblement national se
sont banalisées aujourd'hui le Front
National a réussi à imposer son impôt
sur la vie politique française avant
Marine Le Pen Jean-Marie Le Pen d'une
certaine manière avait fait émerger un
certain nombre de sujets qui sont
devenus des sujets majeurs de la vie
politique française a commencé par
l'immigration qui était d'ailleurs pas
une thématique j'allais dire fondatrice
du Front national la thématique du du
sur l'immigration c'est une thématique
qui arrive au milieu des années 70 qui
n'est pas d'ailleurs celle de Jean-Marie
Le Pen qui est celle de François Duprat
qui est à des proches de Jean-Marie Le
Pen et qui va mourir dans un attentat
avec le fameux slogan un million
d'immigrés un million de chômeurs ça
vient plus tard mais c'est vrai que le
franc national a mis un certain nombre
de thématiques la sécurité le régalienne
l'immigration l'identité au centre du
débat politique depuis près de 40 ans
depuis près de 30 ans Marine Le Pen en
effet elle elle a un peu décalé si vous
voulez cette thématique c'est que elle a
gardé en effet ce qui était le fonds de
commerce qui a fait la réussite
électorale du Front national dans les
années 80 et dans les années 90 mais en
plus elle a investi des thématiques qui
étaient des thématiques qui a été certes
portées par le Front national mais ont
plutôt en second rideau notamment la
question du pouvoir d'achat donc là en
effet il y a une évolution sur la
question juste du personnel vous savez
moi je pense que un parti qui arrive au
pouvoir à un moment donné quoi qu'il
arrive il trouve les compétences pour un
moment donné essayer de gouverner ça je
pense pas que ça soit le sujet principal
pour pour aujourd'hui pour le front pour
le rassemblement national même si quand
on discute par exemple avec Jean-Marie
Le Pen il vous dit ça m'est arrivé de
l'interviewer en 2001 quand ils arrivent
quand il est quand il est quand il était
second tour il dit finalement je me suis
retrouvé dans une situation où je me
suis dit de toute façon on est dans la
capacité de gouverner au regard de nos
de nos de nos propres compétences on va
parler de l'implantation puisque c'est
encore l'un des points faibles du
rassemblement national Quentin et
pourtant c'est l'une des priorités
affichées par les deux candidats à la
présidence Louis a lieu Jordan Bardella
l'implantation locale d'URL les deux en
parlent dans leur discours dans leur
campagne interne pour la présidence du
ici et ça va de pair on le sait avec une
forme de normalisation dont on parlait
dans le reportage de Samia Dechy de
cette formation politique qui se veut de
plus en plus comme étant capable de
gouverner cette recherche de
respectabilité ça passe par un maillage
d'élus dans toute la France alors lors
des dernières municipales en 2020 le
bilan était plus que mitigé cette année
là le parti avait bien remporté
Perpignan avec ses 120000 habitants
cette ville remportée par Lou et Lio
était la plus grosse victoire depuis
celle de Toulon en 1995 le parti qui
parle même de victoire symbolique et qui
met beaucoup en avant cette élection à
ce moment-là mais en 2020 on peut le
dire un peu de villes conquise il y a
bien 7 des 9 mers et reine de l'époque
qui sont reconduits on pense à Fréjus à
Hénin-Beaumont ou encore à Beaucaire
mais que ce soit un Moissac à Mazan ou à
Bruay-la-Buissière on cherche à ce
moment-là les vrais prises de guerre et
la victoire à l'échange locale c'est
pourtant des actes fondateur du
rassemblement national du Front national
de l'époque exactement jusqu'aux années
90 vous allez me démentir si j'éteins
mais le parti il est marginalisé en
France le Front national va réaliser une
première percée aux élections on dit à
l'époque cantonale de 1983 avec des
quelques départements où il réalise de
très bons scores au dessus des 10 %.
mais c'est surtout aux européennes de 94
qu'il fait une percée avec 11 % des voix
et ce sont surtout aux élections
municipales de 95 que le parti est
remarqué avec la victoire à Marignane de
Daniel Simon Pierry à Orange de Jacques
Bompard à Toulon de Jean-Marie Le
chevalier ou même à Vitrolles deux ans
plus tard par Catherine Maigret en 97
c'est Victor on peut le dire elle
provoque à ce moment-là un véritable
choc dans l'opinion publique c'est aussi
par les victoires locales finalement que
le Front national de l'époque a émergé
le Front National a émergé
essentiellement par la figure de
Jean-Marie Le Pen et les prestations
médiatiques de Jean-Marie Le Pen et le
fait que on lui a donné un coup de main
pour qu'il émerge il faut rappeler que
François Mitterrand dans les années 80
finalement suscite la médiatisation de
Jean-Marie Le Pen parce que tout
simplement le Front national avait eu
quelques succès locaux quand même dans
les années 80 en tout début des années
80 le premier si vous voulez le premier
coup de tonnerre médiatique c'est les
municipales partielles de Dreux ou la
droite à l'époque la droite le RPR fait
alliance avec le Front national de
Jean-Pierre sirbois qui est le leader du
Front national dans la zone et il y a
quatre conseillers municipaux du Front
national qui vont rentrer dans une liste
commune ce qui va créer un aimant
médiatique et politique considérable
mais en effet c'est à partir des années
90 que vous avez des premières conquêtes
sur le plan local mais la grande
faiblesse aujourd'hui quand même du
Front national c'est son implantation
j'allais dire territoriale en termes
d'exécutif locaux même s'il y a eu
quelques gains
Marine Le Pen elle remporte des succès
aux élections nationales présidentielles
aux européennes mais en même temps
régional départemental municipal ça a
été des échecs pour le rassemblement
national totalement con Marine Le Pen
prend les reines du parti en étant élu
président du Front national face à Bruno
goniche
on vient d'en parler c'est en disant un
succès et l'implantation locale et là
d'énormes trous dans la raquette elle
n'a pas réussi à s'implanter dans les
territoires et on le voit en fait
d'élection ça se voit sur quelque chose
de très simple d'élection locale en
élections locales c'est rarement les
mêmes candidats il y a énormément de
turnover parce que parce qu'en fait
c'est il y a cette logique aussi de de
purge interne ils ont écarté beaucoup de
candidats et d'élection au local il y a
il pue il y a eu une énorme progression
au niveau des des régionales c'est à
dire que quand Marine Le Pen prend les
reines du parti en en 2011
vous avez des régionales où elle est
allé à 11% c'est vrai qu'en 2015 elle
passe à 28% donc mais dans les
départementales et dans les municipales
c'est vrai que c'est c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué et les dernières élections
locales l'ont confirmé on va parler non
et qui donne des possibilités de gains
sur le plan territorial c'est le fait
d'avoir un groupe parlementaire avec 89
on a véritablement une étape qui a été
franchie en l'occurrence on en parle
2022 évidemment c'est une année
charnière pour le pour le rassemblement
national avec ce score législatif on
peut pas le nier la progression est
forte avec 89 députés le parti multiplie
ses effectifs par 10 ces trois fois plus
que le précédent record pour un groupe
de l'extrême droite qui datait de 1986
ou il y avait à ce moment-là 35 députés
du Front national mais à ce moment-là on
le sait à l'Assemblée nationale était
élu avec de la proportionnelle alors le
parti réalise de bons score dès le
premier tour des législatives en 2022
avec un cumul de 4, de millions de voix
ça fait 18,7% des suffrages c'est 1,2
millions d'électeurs de plus en 2022 par
rapport à 2017 sur la carte de France
que vous voyez on voit qu'il y a un fort
maillage dans le Nord et l'Est et sur la
côte méditerranéenne mais de nouveaux
bastions apparaissent en
nouvelle-aquitaine on a eu plus vu de
députés d'extrême droite depuis les
années 80 et les scores de rassemblement
national ils sont particulièrement
élevés en zone rurale et Perry urbaine
c'est l'autre indication des scrutin de
2022 particulièrement avec l'élection
présidentielle Oriane au premier tour
Marine Le Pen est ainsi arrivé en tête
dans un très grand nombre de communes au
total 2036 très précisément contre 11861
pour Emmanuel Macron mais dans les
grandes villes c'est tout l'inverse la
candidate du rassemblement national
divise son score par 3 par rapport à sa
moyenne nationale en clair on va
dessiner un clivage très fort entre les
électeurs des villes et des électeurs de
la ruralité les votants les plus
éloignés des services publics et du cœur
des métropoles vote plus pour la
candidate d'extrême droite Emmanuel
Macron reste quant à lui convoqué par
son image de président de la
mondialisation heureuse et un nouveau
clivage finalement territorial autour de
Marine Le
pennes
la France périphérique la France des
gilets jaunes on l'avait vu lors des
élections européennes dans les élections
européennes elle avait fait des scores
importants dans les zones où les gilets
jaunes c'était particulièrement
mobilisés c'est elle qui a profité le
plus électoralement du mouvement des
gilets jaunes c'est pas fondamentalement
une surprise parce que tout simplement
elle incarne aujourd'hui un pôle qui est
un pôle plutôt souverainiste en
l'occurrence et le pôle souverainiste
depuis 1992 d'ailleurs depuis le
référendum de Maastricht est fort dans
ces zones là et là-dessus il y a une
espèce de permanence et d'ailleurs le
rassemblement et le Front national ont
toujours fait discours important dans
les zones rurales dès le début
d'ailleurs en l'occurrence c'est pas
tout à fait nouveau on disait Charles
que depuis 50 ans le rassemble Front
national rassemblement national a
toujours eu un Le Pen à sa tête là dans
un mois ce ne sera plus le cas puisque
c'est Jordan verdela ou lui a lieu qui
prendra la présidence du parti est-ce
que ça va changer quelque chose pour le
parti non absolument pas d'ailleurs
les deux candidats le disent eux-mêmes
la patronne reste Marine Le Pen on est
dans un parti déjà on est dans un parti
qui est de tradition bonapartiste le
chef c'est l'incarnation suprême c'est
celui qui va aller à l'élection
présidentielle là avec 80 alors elle a
pu émettre des doutes avant les
législatives il y a quand même très peu
de doux depuis qui est 89 députés à son
national assemblée que Marine Le Pen ne
réfléchit pas et ne se prépare pas déjà
en fait à l'élection présidentielle de
2027 à partir du moment où elle reste la
candidate à la présidentielle ça reste
la patronne et je veux dire
évidemment elle elle ne souhaite pas
finalement se succéder à elle-même à la
présidence du parti parce qu'elle
cherche à avoir une position un peu de
hauteur par rapport aux questions
partisanes à se placer comme candidate
de tous les Français et non pas que d'un
seul parti mais
la ligne idéologique ça sera elle la
ligne programmatique ça serait elle
finalement le futur président du
Rassemblement national que ce soit Louis
Aliot ou plus certainement Jordan
Bardella qui est quand même archi favori
ça va être un rôle qui sera cantonné à
un rôle de ressources humaines de
gestion des fédérations
voilà et qui va qui va qui va devoirs
combien de même en effet ça sera la
première fois depuis 50 ans que le
rassemblement national sera pas au Front
national ne sera pas dirigé par un Le
Pen
dans les faits Marine Le Pen restera la
figure tutélaire de ce parti est-ce que
l'avenir du rassemblement national c'est
le rassemblement national tout seul on
voit ce qui se passe en Europe avec une
union des droites dans plusieurs pays il
y a une victoire en Italie une coalition
protestante
Marine Le Pen ne défend pas cette idée
de l'Union des droites contrairement à
Éric Zemmour et d'ailleurs elle s'est
fondamentalement différenciée des amours
là-dessus c'est-à-dire que elle elle
veut élargir la base d'ailleurs elle dit
très peu elle dit elle dit rarement elle
dit pratiquement jamais qu'elle est de
droite Marine Le Pen elle essaie
d'élargir finalement sa base au delà en
parlant à tous les Français au-delà du
clivage du proche d'une certaine manière
elle a l'air sont en même temps à elle
aussi Marine Le Pen c'est ce qui est
assez intéressant donc elle est pas dans
cette logique là pour l'instant
du fait que elle incarnait l'extrême
droite pour incarner finalement la
candidate des classes populaires en fait
c'est cette c'est sa grande thèse
d'ailleurs elle a beaucoup travaillé sur
sur les travaux de Jérôme Sainte-Marie
bon avec son son livre bloc contre blog
Blog populaire contre bloc hélither
c'est vrai qu'elle ne se place pas dans
le clivage droite-gauche pour elle c'est
fini depuis Maastricht il y a un nouveau
client clivage qui est né qui est donc
en gros
d'un côté les mondialistes dont Emmanuel
Macron serait le chantre et de l'autre
côté les nationalistes même si elle elle
appelle ça les patriotes bon et
nationaliste c'est un terme qui charrie
d'autres choses
et donc en effet elle ne se dit pas de
droit d'ailleurs lors d'un entretien moi
je l'ai posé pourquoi vous faites pas
union des droits et il dit mais la
droite je ne sais pas ce que c'est voilà
donc en effet le côté union des droites
il y a plusieurs possibilités il y a le
fait que Marine Le Pen ne se reconnaisse
pas comme de droite et en plus si vous
voulez quand on prend des exemples ou il
y a eu des unions des droites effectifs
notamment je pense à l'exemple récente
d'Italie vous regardez au niveau
idéologique enfin que ça soit
berlusconix que ce soit Salvini ou que
ce soit mélodie on est sur une droite
conservatrice plus ou moins libéral il
se retrouve sur beaucoup de choses alors
il y en a qui sont Atlantis d'autres qui
sont Prusse mais je veux dire c'est pas
du tout le cas de ce qu'on peut appeler
la droite en France avec une marine de
Pen très étatique un Éric Zemmour
beaucoup plus libéral ou un LR
conservateur et merci pour ce débat de
nous parler de ces 50 ans du
rassemblement national
[Musique]